[Music]
on this Monday night pushing deeper into
Gaza Israel's military vows to intensify
attacks on Gaza City the next deadly
phase in its War Gaza is becoming a
graveyard for
children holding on to Hope a tribute to
the more than 200 hostages held by Hamas
for more than a month we are willing to
pay any price to see our loved ones
again Canada's Premier push back against
carbon price the carbon tax is not a
silver bullet a United call for wider
exemptions in A Renewed fight over
climate policy and bird names for birds
why human names given to dozens of birds
are being
replaced global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us Israeli Defense Forces are
advancing deeper into gaza's largest
city tonight where it claims Hamas
commanders and Fighters are concent ated
almost 1 month since the brutal attack
by Hamas on Southern Israel Israel's
prime minister calls the fight a battle
for civilization Benjamin Netanyahu made
the case to ambassadors from 80
countries today pleading with them to
stand with
Israel this is not a local
battle this is a global battle there is
no substitute for victory we will defeat
Hamas we will dismantle Hamas
if that can be accomplished the human
toll is already staggering the health
Ministry run by Hamas says more than
10,000 people have been killed in Gaza
in four weeks more than 4,000 of them
children Israel disputes those numbers
the World Health Organization believes
they are reliable what is certain is the
next phase will be even more deadly
Israeli forces have encircled Gaza City
it's a densely populated urban area
where thousands of people have been
unwilling or unable able to leave our
coverage tonight begins with Danielle
Hamin and a warning some of the details
are
disturbing yet another night of
unprecedented
bombardment the Israeli military one of
the most powerful in the
world says it struck 450 Hamas
targets and seized a military compound
in the past 24 hours it's now also Dev
Ed the northern and southern parts of
Gaza here's footage the IDF says shows
civilians walking South following the
evacuation order but still in the north
is a field hospital that just received
Medical Aid dropped by a Jordanian
military cargo plane it's believed to be
the first delivery of its kind Israel
says it's not at war with the people of
Gaza but the children of
Gaza keep
dying
this is a massacre says this
man this was the scene in hunis in
southern Gaza where it's meant to be
safer they are all children not a single
adult he says the whole building fell
over them the local Health Ministry run
by Hamas claims that 4,000 children have
been killed since October
7th according to the United Nations no
previous conflict has ever killed so
many staff 88 so far Gaza is becoming a
graveyard for children I'm deeply
concerned about clear violations of
international humanitarian law that we
are witnessing let me be clear no party
to an armed conflict is above
International humanitarian law for weeks
Israel has been focused on gaza's Main
Hospital al-shifa accusing Hamas of
using it as a shield as it conducts
operations underground the IDF released
this video circling in red what it says
is an opening to a
tunnel Monday one of the buildings in
that same Hospital complex was
hit local authorities say one person was
killed and several others were injured
and to the South along the border with
Egypt it was another disappointing day
for Canadians waiting to get out of Gaza
the Rafa border was initially closed and
then it reopened but none of the 400 or
so eligible Canadians were on the list
and so they wait another day Donna all
right Danielle Hamin in Jerusalem
thanks in rala and the occupied West
Bank protesters gathered outside the
office of Canada's representative to the
Palestinian Authority the building was
empty at the time demonstrators
criticized Canada's position on Israel
and called on Canada's government to
stand by the Palestinian people and help
put an end to the Israeli offensive on
Gaza C in the Israeli bombardment of
Gaza are the more than 200 people Hamas
took hostage on October 7th five have
been released it's impossible to imagine
what the rest of them are enduring and
as Mike Armstrong explains their
families fear the world is forgetting
them Mike Al Donna this installation is
called lights of Hope standing in the
middle it's a little like being
surrounded by bright candles and strands
of light but it's something to see as
the sun goes down here in Jerusalem and
these lights in the parking lot of a
basketball arena turn into one massive
beam Rising into the sky it's visible
from several kilometers away meant as a
sign of solidarity now it's from the
ground that you see the individual
lights and what they represent they're
234 each with the name and photo of a
hostage that includes Canadians Vivian
silver and Judy Weinstein both missing
since October
7th now families of the hostages held a
rally outside the knesset the Israeli
Parliament Monday afternoon their
message for the government that its
primary goal should be returning their
loved ones above all
else even if it says to release all the
Palestinian prisoners to create a
ceasefire to to bring fuel to to Gaza we
are willing to pay any price to see our
loved ones again my mother is a very
strong lady but she's 63 and she will
have her birthday on on this Friday 64
so we want her to celebrate with us the
plan for this site is to keep it going
as long as it takes and to remove a
light each time a hostage is returned
the installation's been up for a week
already and in that time they haven't
had the chance to take down even a
single light Donna Mike Armstrong in
Jerusalem The American Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin has left the
Middle East with no progress on getting
Israel to agree on humanitarian pauses
or on getting more hostages out today he
met with turkey's foreign affairs
minister after a frantic weekend of
travel across the region even limited
humanitarian Aid is getting into Gaza
and blinkin says he's not giving up and
I think you'll see in the days ahead uh
that that assistance can expand in in in
significant ways so that more gets into
people who who need it and gets to the
people who need it as well as making
sure that people can continue to come
out of Gaza Lincoln says he hopes an ual
pause will also prevent the conflict
from spreading he has visited turkey
Israel Jordan Iraq and the West Bank on
this trip including that unannounced
visit with Palestinian Authority
president Mahmud abas Pope Francis today
condemned anti-Semitism war and
terrorism in a written speech shared
with European rabbis at the Vatican the
pope did not read the speech he said he
was feeling unwell today in it he said
his thoughts and prayers go above all
else to everything that has happened in
the last few weeks a reference to the
October 7th Hamas attack in Israel and
the ensuing War the pope also condemned
the rise in anti-semitic incidents
across Europe in Nigeria an explosion at
the Canadian High Commission in the
capital killed two maintenance workers
and wounded two
others thick plumes of black smoke could
be seen billowing out of the building
it's believed the fire started when a
tank of diesel exploded during
maintenance work on the generators
Global Affairs Canada said an
investigation will be conducted but it
appears to have been an accident former
American president Donald Trump was on
the witness stand today defending his
wealth it's a civil fraud trial in New
York Trump is accused of massively
inflating the value of his properties in
order to get favorable loans as with all
the cases against him he calls it a
political Witch
Hunt Trump clashed with a judge in court
but kept silent when he ran into
reporters later as Jackson prco reports
the outcome of this case could affect
Trump's business
Empire the former president was defiant
before he even took the stand we have to
take away from the thugs that we deal
with and the horrible people that
actually must hate our country to do
this inside the court things didn't go
much better as Donald Trump repeatedly
assailed the judge hearing the case and
the attorney general who brought the
charges calling it a very very unfair
trial at one point Justice Arthur and
garon pleaded with Trump's lawyers to
call their client saying I beseech you
to control him if you can if you can't I
will I will excuse him and draw every
negative inference that I can soon after
Trump faced questions about whether he
knowingly inflated the size and value of
his real estate Assets in an alleged
effort to get favorable terms on loans
and insurance policies they said Mar's
worth $18 million Mar's worth anywhere
from probably 50 to 100 times more than
that on the stand Trump acknowledged his
role in helping assemble documents
outlining the value of his properties
last week Trump's Sons tried to blame
company accountants for any errors at
the end of the day the only thing that
matters are the facts and the
numbers and numbers my friends don't lie
the judge has already found that Trump
his sons Don Jr and Eric and his company
committed persistent and repeated fraud
what's still to be decided is the
penalty they should pay this really is
the biggest threat to him of all of
these cases because uh it goes to his
core argument that he's a savy
businessman prosecutors have asked the
judge to impose a $250 million penalty
on Trump and bar him from ever doing
business in the state of New York again
yet the former president and his
supporters are already looking past the
facts of this case claiming it's all
political persecution Jackson prosco
Global News
Washington as winter appr approaches a
political debate is heating up keep the
heat on and take the tax
off MPS have voted to reject a
non-binding motion put forward by the
leader of the official opposition Pierre
PV calling on the liberal government to
extend a carbon tax pause on home
heating oil and expand it to all forms
of fossil fuels used to heat homes today
provincial premieres met in Halifax some
of them calling on the federal
government to go back to the drawing
board on the carbon tax Heidi petruk
reports
the meeting of Canada's Premier was
originally build as a discussion on
healthc Care and housing but questions
about ottawa's carbon tax and the
federal government's recent exemption
for home heating oil had them more than
willing to weigh in the right thing to
do we feel for the is for the Canadian
government to extend fairness to all
Canadian families that refrain heard
many times ever since the federal
government put a three-year carbon tax
exemption on home heating oil last month
a move seen by Prairie politicians as
favoring other provinces especially
Atlantic Canada where oil is most
commonly used to keep homes warm all
this is doing is just causing unfairness
making life less affordable and really
harming our most vulnerable as we get
into the winter season we would love it
if there were a silver silver bullet on
climate change but the carbon tax is not
a silver bullet conservative Premier on
the East Coast where constituents
benefit most from ottawa's carbon car
vote also taking aim at the federal
liberal policy I understand the concerns
of my colleagues from other parts of the
country and I would ask I would ask that
the the federal government address those
concerns in a meaningful way I think
it's time to have a real serious look at
this carbon tax and what it has done
what it's doing and the negative impact
it's having this latest situation with
the federal government uh it didn't have
to happen the way it did although this
political science Professor argues
politicking should be put aside to
address the climate crisis there is a
lack of political will around making
this issue you know solved and there is
political will around backing into your
corner and you know doubling down and
say I'm I want what I want I'm not going
to change premier's meetings typically
don't result in outright policy but
rather take the temperature on the
relationship between the federal
government and provincial leaders and it
seems from this meeting that
relationship is fairly chilly when it
comes to the carbon tax Donna all right
Heidi petruk in Halifax thanks hundreds
of thousands of Quebec workers on the
picket line coming up what the
province's public sector employees are
demanding plus the murders of four
indigenous women back in the spotlight
the accused killer enters his
[Music]
plea in Quebec public sector workers
held a one-day strike over lagging
contract negotiations with the
provincial government about 420 90,000
workers were off the job today
disrupting schools health care
facilities and Social Services four
unions representing what they call a
common front say they will stage a
three-day strike later this month if a
new deal isn't reached the government's
latest offer includes a 10.3% salary
increase over 5 years and a one-time
payment of $1,000 to each worker the
union says that doesn't cover inflation
in Manitoba a man accused of killing
four indigenous women has pleaded not
guilty to four counts of first de ree
murder 35-year-old Jeremy scabi has been
behind bars for more than a year he's
accused of killing Rebecca cona Morgan
Harris Mercedes Myron and a woman the
community has named Buffalo Woman
investigators believe the remains of
Harrison myON are in the prairie green
landfill site north of Winnipeg some of
con's remains were found in May of 2022
in a separate landfill run by the City
scab's jury trial is scheduled for April
his lawyer is arguing he should have the
right to trial by judge
alone poppy stories ahead the stories
you can learn by scanning your
[Music]
poppy there are many ways Canadians
choose to pay tribute on Rememberance
Day and it's often the personal stories
that mean the most now the Royal
Canadian Legion is making it easier to
find those stories it's a digital
campaign that involves scanning your
poppy with a smartphone as teria isri
explains it's not only helping recognize
veterans sacrifices it's honoring their
lives so we're going to line up here
poppy every veteran has a story and so
does every poppy now this is the story
of Keith Bradley morale log on to Poppy
stories. CA take a photo of the lapel
and unlock the history and in this scan
we see the story of Joseph Hector
Campbell from Nova Scotia different
soldiers from different backgrounds who
all share something in common they were
once peacekeepers chosen to commemorate
the 75th anniversary of Canadian
peacekeeping and me a Canadian with a
story to
remember to the legion it's a way of
making the poppy more personal so that
if you don't have a veteran in your
family or you maybe don't have a friend
who's a veteran it gives you a way to
remember somebody very deeply very
personally you have their name and you
have a little bit about their service
the virtual poppy campaign features the
profiles of 50 Fallen peacekeepers
including Master Corporal Mark isfeld
who also has an exhibit here at the
Canadian war museum so there's Master
Corporal Mark isfeld Master Corporal
isfeld was a combat engineer from
Courtney British Columbia it's almost as
good as a fish dad he was part of a
United Nations mission in the 1990s and
died while clearing mines scattered
during the war in the former Yugoslavia
they would often be greeted by groups of
of children these are children who are
just caught in this war zone
uh and he his heart went out to them to
bring them Comfort Master Corporal
isfeld asked his mother to knit dolls
known as Izzy dolls which are still
handed out today the legions campaign is
one more tribute to isfeld and others
like him by remembering that each poppy
holds a piece of History teria isri
Global News
Ottawa on Saturday Global News will have
special coverage including a live
presentation of the Remembrance Day
service in Ottawa our coverage begins at
10:30 a.m. eastern on global and all of
our streaming
platforms for the birds next why they're
getting their own names instead of human
ones it's kind of strange when you
really think about it that birds have
been given human names and as
hummingbird Cooper Hawk dozens of birds
have been named after people not only do
they have nothing to do with the bird's
traits or habitats the the names can
sometimes be traced to some unsavory
characters Eric senson explains why it's
now been decided Birds should have bird
names there are fewer Birds to see this
time of year in much of the country
we're thinking about the winter finches
arriving but we're getting those Hardy
birds that are still sort of you know
coming from the north and are are
passing through but a new challenge
facing birders like Carl kzi will be
scores of name changes the whole sort of
field of bir watching is is is aimed at
being able to identify the birds the
American ornithological society is doing
away with birds named after people for
example the Scots orial needs to go say
critics named after Winfield Scott a US
general who oversaw the forced
relocation of indigenous peoples almost
200 years ago and Townsen warbler common
to western Canada was named for John
Townsen we know that John Townsen and
was actually involved in uh digging up
uh the graves of especially indigenous
people uh for the sake of um scientific
research at the time it evokes thoughts
of an unfair unjust time in our history
the ornithological society has struck a
diverse committee to come up with new
names this is an opportunity to correct
some of these injustices and to be a
little less sexist a little less
misogynist a little less racist and a
lot more inclusive adjusting to the new
names could be a challenge for oldtime
birders but for newcomers more
descriptive names could make learning
easier the Royal Ontario Museum has vast
numbers of birds cataloged such as
Wilson's warbler Mark peek looked over a
male and female both have a semblance of
a black cap so if they were going to
rename Wilson's warbler why not name it
something like a black cap warbler he
says the name changes should encourage a
new generation of birders to take an
interest it's critically important right
now because Birds numbers are in steep
declines and we need to get people
inspired and engaged in birds so instead
of human monikers new names may consider
the features the habitat or merely birds
of a feather that flock together Eric
senson Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna Fen tonight's your
Canada is Hinton Alberta we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at
global.com and thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye